[Music]
new photos of Meg Ryan supporting her
friend Michael J fox in a rare public
appearance for the actress who's chosen
to stay out of the spotlight in recent
years he did my best but on Thursday Meg
stepped out for a screening of Michael's
new documentary still looking happy as
she visits with the Back to the Future
star and his wife Tracy Paulin who also
appears in the movie that looks back at
her husband's Incredible Journey to deny
that pardon me that wants to continue to
go on and do things is is to quit from
Michael's Teen Idol years I get it I was
big I was bigger than bubble gum to the
diagnosis that change everything
Auto animated
Parkinson's disease I love the way they
did it anything which they applied this
whole footage to the narrative to my
story and they found situations in films
that acted at them it's actually
happened in my life so if you're clever
and it's really good film
as for Meg this comes over a year after
her last public outing that was to
support another friend her in the cut
director Jane Campion who helmed the
2021 film The Power of the dog Jane just
changed my life speaking of the
director's chair last year Meg announced
her plans to get behind the camera when
she shared the poster for what happens
later a romantic comedy she's also set
to star in with David Duchovny no new
updates for the movie but Meg's caption
at the time here we go
[Music]
meanwhile Meg status as one of the
reigning queens of the rom-com got a
shout out on and just like that's first
season sorry sorry have your night I I
shouldn't have come who am I Meg Ryan no
Miranda but we can't blame anyone
wanting to take after a movie icon who
steps out for a good cause
[Music]
thank you